[Music]
the national library of medicine's
native voices
native people's concepts of health and
illness exhibition
continuing its nationwide tour by
traveling from the great plains of north
dakota
to the mountains of alaska
[Applause]
[Music]
the grand opening of the exhibition
coincided with the first day of the
national congress of american indians
which was held at the stunning denia
center in downtown anchorage
[Music]
at the opening session of the congress
the alaska native south central
foundation
recognized the positive contributions
nlm director dr donald lindberg has made
to native people
by way of the exhibition the national
library of medicine were very careful to
observe our cultural beliefs
and respect our traditional ways as they
accomplish this work
across the nation as native people we
believe in sharing what we know and
passing the knowledge
down through the generations and this
exhibition is consistent with those
ideals
and the educational value is immense and
widespread
and on behalf of the national congress
of american indians all the people of
alaska it is my pleasure to bestow upon
dr limbert
a token of our appreciation and a thank
you for his long-term commitment and
efforts toward this achievement
please applaud with me and recognize dr
lindbergh
i think it's very important for natives
to hear from the other natives about
successes and how you can live a nice
healthy
lifestyle and bringing an awareness from
listening to these
real life stories
[Music]
the native voices exhibition is visiting
multiple locations during its year-long
alaskan tour
at the close of the national congress of
american indians annual meeting
the exhibition moved to the alaska
native heritage center
where alaska native youth showcased the
many facets of their culture
they'd use this right here it's a
storytelling knife
and as you can see it's made of a lower
jaw bone of a
caribou
many alaska native people contributed
stories to the native voices exhibition
including village elders healers and
physicians
i really enjoy watching my people
talk about these problems because i grew
up
where we didn't talk about the bad stuff
you know the elders they didn't want to
dwell on the negativity
but we need to face it in order to heal
so i really appreciate this exhibit
the next stop on the alaskan tour is the
south central foundation's primary care
center
the primary care center blends western
medical practices
with traditional healing in a culturally
appropriate setting
that includes art and a medicinal garden
full of
indigenous plantings
in 2011 the south central foundation was
awarded the prestigious malcolm baldrige
national quality award
for the success of its nuka system of
care
nuka is an alaska native word used for
strong giant structures
and living things it is the name given
to the health care system created
managed and owned by alaska native
people to achieve physical
mental emotional and spiritual wellness
the native voices exhibition will also
visit the south central foundation's
bentanuta valley native primary care
center in wasilla
and the whammy regional medical
education program at the university of
alaska
at every stop on the tour communities
are encouraged to augment the native
voices exhibition
by showcasing their own art and
artifacts or hosting it during powwows
or other community celebrations
we are very fortunate to be able to have
the exhibit and let our voices be heard
i still remember when i was telling the
story that i didn't tell people i was
native
and that if i could pass with something
other than native then i
i made it and i felt ashamed of that so
when i hear the stories on the exhibit
i know i'm not alone and that we're not
the only people in the struggle
alaska hawaii lower 48. all indigenous
peoples of the world
[Music]
native voices will travel to sites in
hawaii and oklahoma
and then to indian reservations native
health and cultural centers
and regional medical libraries
nationwide